hello everyone and welcome back to what
could be the
absolutely best game that was played
yesterday and maybe even in the
tournament so far
yeah it's young [ __ ] of duda versus
daniel lubov and someone sent me an
email i think two
two weeks ago maybe even a month ago
that the daniel's uh
middle name is dimitrijevic so uh making
him daniel dimitrijevic
making him also a triple d so uh they
suggested that maybe we should refer to
him with the nickname of triple d
so i don't know what do you guys think
about that is it a good idea should we
just stick to do both i don't know yeah
i guess it's uh you know open for
suggestions
now that being said uh crazy crazy game
features
uh five queens as you might have uh
imagined and also features an
improvement on a game that is uh
96 years old uh played by none other
than the great alexander alejand so
without further ado let's check it out
uh so
do that with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to c
knight to f6 c4 uh e6 knight to f3 and
d5 so a normal queen's gambit declined
we have knight to c3 and
c6 uh we have e3 preparing to develop
the light square bishop and here
knight b the d7 uh black of course
always waits for white to develop the
light square bishop before capturing on
c4 so bishop to d3
and only now do both captures d captures
and c for bishop captures and
b5 so this is uh i think the oldest
possible way to
play this line even even i have read
about this some 20 years ago
uh bishop back to be a d3 and bishop to
b7 now now black
solves the problem of developing the
light square bishop you're going to get
the rook into the game push c5 and then
your light square
bishop becomes a a strong piece
so here castles by doodah and now a6
uh defending that b5 pawn once again as
you do want to play c5
so e4 grabbing more space in the center
and now without hesitation
c5 so now the light square bishop comes
alive and you are putting pressure on
the center here
and here uh most mostly played today is
d5 but e5 is also playable
i just i guess at the absolute top level
that
the engines play it i guess d5 is a bit
more precise but for a rapid game
between two humans
uh e5 works just as well so e5 and
now knight to d5 and this is actually
a very very tricky line because if uh if
dubois accepts this
and goes for c captures on d4 then we go
into this
knight captures on b5 bishop captures on
f3
attacking the queen queen captures and
now knight to d5 the knight still being
under attack
knights the d6 with check captures
captures and
now just knights day e5 attacking the
queen the bishop and you will recollect
the pawn
so just everything gets traded off for
example queen e4 captures captures in
the now queen captures on d6
and if queen captures on d4 just castles
and it's a
you know equal equalisher game uh white
has a bishop black has a knight but
white does have two against one on the
queen side
so it's hard to say but both of them i
think know this and agree that this is
not worth playing so knights to d5
and now knight to g5 putting some
pressure on black's king side here
knight captures on c3b captures and here
we reach the position that alexander
alejan had against
grigoriev in his 1925 simultaneous
exhibition in geneva
and even the great attacker alejan
himself played knight
back to e4 here interestingly this is
the
uh sorry after after bishop d7 after
bishop d7 uh alejand played knights to
e4 here which is the strongest move
recommended by the engine so even alejan
knew that
but the duda doesn't go for the retreat
with knights to e4 but rather goes for
knight captures on e6 and this is a new
move in the position
so already we have a completely new game
already as of move 14 and i find
i find it uh i mean amazing that
alejand did not go over knight captures
an e6 because even alien knew that
this isn't good but duda decides to try
it out against the dubo so
let's see what happens here knight
captures an e6 you have to capture this
otherwise you're just dead lost
so f captures an e6 and now queen to h5
with check and now uh duda was probably
expecting uh dubo to play king to f8
because
it is the reasonable thing to do and you
do not allow white to sacrifice the
bishop here on g6 so here
uh if king to f8 was played then of
course we play f4 f5
we want to open up the f-file attack the
king here and if king j8
still f5 and now we get this position
which uh
duda most likely had analyzed at home
and prepared for this and dubo would
have to struggle over the board and the
waste
time as this is a rapid game but just in
in case you're
interested uh you can defend sort of
against this but you have to play
knight captures on e5 now as the bishop
here is undefended
d captures queen captures on d3 and now
even
f6 so it seems like black is getting
overrun but
here comes queen to d5 or queen e4 it
doesn't really matter
going after checkmate here then white
defense checkmate with queen g5 and
threatens checkmate and then we just
trade everything off
queen captures we have queen captures
bishop captures attacks the rook
king captures and now g captures an f6
we have e captures on f6
attacking the bishop here bishop to d6
and now
uh i guess you could even push f7 with
checking g7 and bishop to g5 going after
this uh
check winning the rook here and after
the rook moves rook h to f8 now rocate
to d1 and basically we get this position
where white is uh
more active he has a beautiful pass pawn
here but
black is up upon so again it's a sort of
a trade-off white should be better
because you know
activity above all but uh i don't know
uh so of course this is only one line
that's uh
really forcing and um well
it plays out like this but there are of
course many more uh the duda knows and
do both uh i guess reluctant to try them
out goes g6
instead so he's gonna try out his luck
here so g6
bishop captures this is an insta capture
h captures and now not going for the
rook of course if you capture the rook
then knight f8
and already black is doing great the
knight is defended the g pawn is
defended you're gonna play queen d5
threat and checkmate you're gonna castle
queenside
everything is uh going in your favor so
instead duda grabs the g
pawn queen captures on g6 and now king
to f8
and now you can see that there are
some very thematic ideas here like uh
after the bishop moves the rook can come
into the game and it's gonna be it's
gonna be very hard for
the black king to defend this so first
of course the bishop comes into the game
with
check now black has no moves black has
to give up the rook
rook captures queen captures and now
king to g8
and now queen to g6 with check now
going to the f file is uh not a good
idea because f4 f5 just opens up the
file so king h8
and now comes uh queen to h6 check once
again we have kink the g8 and now we
want to pick up the e6 pawn with
check so only now queen captures on e6
and now
king to g7 not allowing any further
queen to h6 checks because then
you really have to worry about stuff
like this uh and here
you could try a lot of things uh but as
duda is expecting knight of f8
uh that the queen will be under attack
he doesn't go for any checks right away
he first
brings the rook into the game rook eight
to d1 and now he always has this option
of going for the rook lift but also he
has the option of rookie one and then
just pushing those central pawns so
this is just a disgustingly difficult
position to defend for black
so knights the f8 by dubo and now as the
queen is under attack
queen to g for check king the h8 and now
d5 and look at these uh
two monstrosities in the center of the
board
not there uh so knights the h7
uh now blocking any checks and now d6
and here
maybe a slight improvement for white
rook after e1 as
uh this way you open up the bishop's
diagonal and you don't have to rush it
you want to play rookie one put both
rooks behind the past pawns and maybe
then push
but it's a rapid game they are both very
long time so they have to make these
moves on the go
so d6 attacking the bishop and now
bishop to h4
uh we have e6 now those two pawns are
incredibly strong
queen to f6 not allowing it to lock the
queen out of the game with
e7 then you also lose the bishop so
queen to f6
and now e7 uh we have bishop to c6 the
bishop now tries to help out
with uh those those past pawns and now
g3
pushing back the dark square bishop and
now the thing is you cannot go back if
bishop g5 just
f4 and that's it bishop to h6 you're
just going to play rook f to e1 and
there is no defending this uh
it's j you're just going to get overrun
and of course rook the g8 always runs
into queen captures and g8 so you don't
even have to worry about that king
captures d7 and that's just it
that's uh that's quite the position here
so after g3 we have the instant rook the
g8 by duba
attacking do this queen and now queen to
h5
of course for those of you who are maybe
new to chess you cannot capture the
bishop because after queen captures the
g pawn is pinned
so you're just gonna lose the queen so
the queen has to move queen h5
and now we have queen captures and c3
dooba comes
calmly grabs a pawn and he says okay if
you don't win now then i'm gonna start
pushing my past pawns and here
uh again what do you play here uh
interestingly
uh you cannot go for the bishop and this
is what dubo found if you capture the
bishop dangerous queen f3 and you're
getting checkmated there's no stopping
this
so here uh duda finds the brilliant rook
to d5 he
cuts off the light square bishop and now
what do you play here
again the time is ticking and the dubo
has to react to this really quickly
uh and uh he plays uh bishop captures on
the e5 but
there was also the very interesting
bishop to g5
however that runs into rook captures on
g5 and you just want to get the
defenders of the back rank rook captures
and g5
now you bring the queen into the game
with check and after bishop characters
you're going to play queen captures with
check rook the g8 and the d7 and now uh
you know who can make uh
what's what here after queen to d4 you
are probably defending
but it's a very very ugly position to
face so while this was in the position
uh double decided to grab the rook
bishop captures on d5 which is not a
problem
queen captures on d5 and now comes
knight
to f6 by dubois here the absolute best
was bishop captures on e7 you just
have to give up some material to weaken
those past pawns and then go after the
pawn and now the thing is after queen to
f7 going after
the rook now you have knight f6
defending the rook
the knight is defended here also rook to
e1 is impossible
and next a queen to e5 followed by queen
captures on e7 is coming so this is
absolutely best for double
however duval played knight to f6 with
an attack on the queen
saying i i i you know better to get this
movie in before
i decided on anything else but now uh
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the winning idea for duda
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the
uh the the nice queen sacrifice and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
it's queen captures on g8 just simply
removing uh the defender of the back
rank we have knight captures on g8
uh and now comes uh e8 with queen it
wouldn't help if you captured with the
king uh because the
the d-pawn is also coming up the board
so the ship the f6
and now queen to h5 with check you could
also just play d7
uh but uh first duda wants to throw in
some checks
uh queen to h5 check king g7 and now
rook the d1 advan now preparing to
advance the pawn
knight to h6 by dubois and now d7
uh we have knight to f7 now both the
bishop and the knight are guarding the
queening square and now
queen to g4 with check king of f8 and
now queen to e6
uh and here dubo says all right there's
not much to be done here let's just
start pushing those past pawns so c4
and now comes uh uh rook to d5 and
that's a very nice rope lift if you go
for this check it doesn't really do
anything king
here and the squares are still defended
and you can't
uh just trade everything off give up the
rook for two pieces because a duval also
has
past pawns here so instead after c4 we
have
rook to d5 an excellent rook lift going
for rook to f5
b4 dubof continues pushing his pass
pawns and now
rook to f5 now with a double attack on
the bishop so dubo defends it king to g7
and now king the g2 but now uh
adubo also uh continues pushing his past
pawn so b3
a captures c captures and now now for
the final time
pause the video and win the game for
duda while i give you a couple of
seconds this is not an easy one
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it you are a true master of the game
because this move as
is incredibly hard to find and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it's actually
rook to f4 and this is just uh awesome
stuff now rook to g4 is coming
and there's not much for for black to do
here just to give you an example
uh if black continues pushing the pawn
then first we bring a queen into the
game
b8 queen this is crucial have to remove
one of the defenders from the king
knight captures on the e8 and now only
now rook to g4
with check king h6 and now queen to f5
threatening checkmate so what do you
play here only one way to defend and
that's
queen to c6 check king has to move or
playing f3
and now move the bishop so now the queen
is guarding the
uh mating square but now queen to f4
check
king to h7 and queen to e5 again going
for checkmate here
and finally after you block this with
something uh
let's say if you try queen to f6 it
doesn't really work because just queen
h5
check and again you get checkmated queen
h6 queen to f5 check
king the h8 queen to e5 check now king
h7 you're gonna capture an e7 with
check king h8 queen capture so total
annihilation
king h7 and queen to g8 is now checkmate
and another thing if after queen to e5
you don't block with queen to f6 you
could try something like queen to c to
check
but it's insufficient king h3 you're
gonna play queen to g6 now try and offer
your queen for some counter play
as you also hope to queen your pawn but
just queen captures an e7 check first
knight f7 now you capture rook captures
king captures
and now the queen very easily collects
the pawn just queen e6 check king g7 and
queen to b6 and that pawn is going
nowhere
so rook to f4 uh incredible move duda
misses it unfortunately he goes for the
pawn grab queen captures on a6 but now
dubo gets another pawn move in
and that's a b2 and now this pawn is
much closer to queening
and all of the lines that we've shown uh
no longer work
so queen to b6 guarding the queening
square and now
bishop to d8 trying to force the queen
away from the b
file so duba can queen the pawn but now
duda goes for rook captures on f7 uh
this is comes with
czech king captures and queen captures
on d8 now so eliminating both of them
but allowing duba to uh go uh bring the
queen into the game but
this loses if duval brings the queen
into the game we have this queen to e8
to check and after king g7 just the
eighth queen and
that's it black is getting checkmated
because at the end of the day
white is up three pawns so even if the
queens get traded off white just wins
the king and pawn end game
queen b7 check you have one more check
to deliver but just king h3 and now
there are no more useful checks uh black
is just done for so instead after this
queen d8 move uh
uh we have queen to c6 with check and
now comes
f3 just uh defending here uh and now
only now uh b1 with queen here was
dubose final final moment where he could
have saved the game
with queen to see to check b but it's so
tricky to find i'm just gonna show it
because i know you guys
enjoy it point is that after king h3 you
have queen f5 check and now white has to
repeat
this check check check check check uh
king h3 queen of five check
because if you try and win this and go
up the board let's say king h4
then queen to h7 check king to g4 and
now queen to g6 check now the problem is
after king h3 you have queen the e6
check and now you guard
this square that's the point after
anything the king moves or g4 now you
bring a queen into the game and the
white
doesn't have this check white has no
useful checks and you will not be
queening your pawn
so this is the idea and that this was a
dubai's last hope
but here duval brought the queen into
the game but now it's
duda's dude's turn to start checking so
queen to e8 to check
king to g7 now queen e5 check king to h7
and now queen to h5 check dubo wants to
set up everything perfectly so
it will be easier for his uh queen to
defend the king even though queening
right away was also possible but
with little time on the clock you want
to make sure that dubois doesn't have
some sort of a tricky perpetual so kng7
uh queen to g for check king to h6 and
now
queen to f4 check king h5 g4 with
check king to g6 and only now that you
freed up the g3 square for the king a
little bit
now you bring a queen into the game and
here we have uh four queens on the board
and with the one queen that was already
sacrificed that's
that's five queens so here queen c to c2
with check and now uh queen d to d2 here
was
uh there there was a possibility here if
uh duda went king to h3 then duvet still
wins after queen to f1 check
it's very nice so we're going to show it
king to h4
queen f to f2 now with check king h3 now
queen g to check
king h4 and only now we capture and
after captures and captures this is
checkmate as the king covers these two
squares
so after this queen c to c2 with check
uh duda just played queen
d to d2 and it was in this position that
daniel dubo resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh you cannot trade queens because then
it's just a queen
queen's end game with white being up
three pawns that's completely winning
and if you try to avoid the trade maybe
go for some queen g1
action you're very quickly losing this
for example queen h6 check
king f7 you're gonna go queen to d7
check and that's just it
if you go up the board you're getting
checkmated so you have to play something
like this
but now even this queen to e6 check
the queen cannot capture due to the pin
king f8 and now queen d
captures and we have a beautiful
checkmate here with the two queens
so a nice just threesome as we call it
on this channel
uh so yeah uh really really wild stuff
definitely the best game of yesterday
but i i do think it's also the absolute
best game of the entire tournament so
far uh the tournament is still going on
so we'll see what happens but uh
way to go that's that's that's the kind
of chess that we enjoy seeing so
congratulations to both of them
for playing such a such a wonderful game
uh so
and also here are the standings after
after three rounds so
uh the guys on the left are the ones who
go uh further into the tournament and
the people on the right unfortunately
drop out uh it's also from chess 24th as
you can see there
so uh magnus carlsen uh winning the
tournament with nine and a half points
with anish giri
uh wesley saw eleven aaron and maxine
bashar lagrave young sister dudas
those are uh the top eight that are
continuing the tournament
and uh leaving the tournament are hikaru
nakamura sam shankland janipanishi
gujarati linear dominguez alexander
grayshock matthias bluebaum
and the ding lyran who for some reason
lost pretty much all of the games i have
no idea what's
uh what's up with that and uh how is
being not
uh just annihilating everyone but ever
since the
this whole situation in the world
started uh things started playing poorly
in the candidates in here and everywhere
uh and yeah i don't know if you can hear
that my neighbors are doing some
redecorating so there's a lot of
drilling but luckily we have uh
reached the end of our video uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
uh i would like to thank a mystery
person
a mystery person uh julian moyk harold
floor and
another mystery person for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this nice tournament uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day